so high level face the father
I won Oscar for Christopher so first of
all let me tell you something first ask
you something there's a maximum of rania
which says let you kill you fool of a
nurse that was AHA so that a soul is not
given more than what I can handle yeah
yeah so if someone has a feeling of
homosexuality
yeah so I'm saying like as a Muslim he
feels like Oh attracted or sexually
attracted to do open to the same gender
yeah as Muslims we say at that point is
not sinful because based on that Maxim
do you see how that works so basically
if you're any human being like yourself
whatever
if you feel again physically attractive
it's basically a soul is not or human
being itself is not given more than it
can handle in terms of ability so if you
can't control yourself and it's just
something that's within you
yeah and you're feeling like oh you know
I'm attracted to the same gender yeah
sometimes you can't necessarily like you
know control that so I mean so if that's
the case you're not sinful for feeling
like that yeah because Islam doesn't
hold you to account for how you feel you
see what I mean but let me be clear as
well yeah because that onus should be
quite referring and like I want to also
be honest with you
aslam when it comes to homosexuality it
forbids homosexuality in a sexual sense
so what I mean to say when I say that is
that say for example a man once I want
to have sex with another man yeah okay
so we would say that's morally not all
right thing to do it's all good thing to
do you see what I'm saying now if he
feels good this is a man all right
morally it says the wrong thing for
human beings to do according to the
Koran now the reason why I would say I
think this is the argument now like in
the West they say look man that's okay
you can have that valley that's fine but
a new public view this yeah say we
believe in the West here that so long as
you're not harming anyone else you can
do everyone is that would you agree that
maximum
yes I guess yeah well no no yeah as long
as you know allows you know how many
knows well you have to on Stuart Mill is
an English philosopher and he talks
about the harm on liberty the hump rules
of the area you guys learn politics or
something what do you do trust me guys
man I've done it all before as what John
Stuart Mill or the humper in support
yeah yeah and he obviously further from
what Ben if you remember his father was
close friends with whom Bentham yeah and
he grew up with Jerry before was in
utilitarianism so he realized that
utilitarianism had like the issue of the
hump like cause harm so he put a cap on
that or he kind of refined a theory of
utilitarianism with what he called the
harm principle you remember like in your
study Sam do you know what let me ask
you a question there find this - yeah
okay the Moscow questions
straightforward yeah
do you accept do you think faster - not
all things are safe a mother and a son
they can wear protection
all right your protection yourself
getting too involved into a sexual
relationship do you consider that
morally acceptable
I know I wouldn't because their mother
is there's an older I think age comes
into it I think the mother is a guardian
of the Sun and is responsible
I wouldn't think it's okay for a teacher
to have consent even if the vice is
anything I wouldn't think it's okay for
a teacher to have sex to the pupil
because there's the power dynamic make
this through them the same with the
mother and a son than the parent and I
think again I think if the Sun if the
Sun had reached the age of 18 which in
England we agree there is an age for
conceptual consent and like you're an
adult now and you can yeah if 18 is the
age of sexual consent you can make a
decision as an independent adult you
have to have sex with who everyone
therefore if a mother and an 18 year old
decided to have sex then
I would consider it very strange I'm
accepting what you're saying now all I'm
saying is that if we're accepting that
there Maxim that we're being morally
consistent with is the hum principle it
they max them basically that you can do
everyone so long as you know how many
one else yeah
then I feel it would be a contradiction
of the hum principle if we said okay you
have one rule for homosexuals and a
different rule for those people who have
practiced incest I'm saying is can I ask
you a question what would what would be
in your minds the difference between
incest and homosexuality I explained
that like mothers have power over their
sons and like the responsibility to
bring them up so can I say something
yeah the things that you've mentioned
and
and also there's our paradise inherent
love and there's an inherent connection
due to that relationship yeah basically
bf makes it like I'm naturalistically
unacceptable there's there's a bond in
which demands a certain responsibility
from the old Guardian okay can I tell
you something I'll be honest with you
yeah this power dynamic issue is an
issue which is first of all at some time
if you don't example if you've done
their philosophy and PPE and stuff yeah
so I can tell you that you've got I
remember doing this when I was in their
uni do you guys remember like we do in
power like did you cover like three
theories of power
Robert Robert Dahl his conception of
power back rats and Barrett's you know
who's not all right so basically there
are different conceptions of power yeah
from a from a philosophical perspective
it's difficult to actually track what
power is Robert Bell who said that power
is the ability for person a to change
person B's ability to do or he otherwise
doesn't want to do some of it then
there's a second layer of power which is
backpacks and Barrett C advance
Tennessee etcetera so first of all we'll
talk about power dynamics and obviously
former philosophical perspective you've
got Michael from power in a in a very
difficult thing to define and that's why
you've got so many different people
defining it in different ways my
microphone Kobach rats and Barrett's
rope with the problem now what I'll say
to you that
so using this construct which is power
to to deem something is I'm immoral
it's basically arguing in a circle
because first you'd have to prove that
it exists in a certain way and then
you'd have to identify how this power
exists in a certain relationship do so I
mean so but I would say this I would say
that I'll be completely honest with you
from 1/8 you guys would you consider
these have like non-religious yeah so
like not you don't believe in the higher
source yeah right I do believe in
something that underlies everything so I
would okay fine I'm a movie but you
don't believe in good I
[Music]
I haven't sort of haven't established I
haven't established what this underlying
something is but but he may be good
there he's a multiplicity of some kind
okay I'm with you what can I say is of
the camp if you don't believe in God my
question to you would be a
straightforward question
where do you derive your morals in terms
of objective morality do you think you
can get objective morality without an
all-knowing all-wise entity that can
detect the void I think objective
knowledge can can still be apparent to
me through this sort of rationale and
reasoning between individuals which is
like this underlying something is an
underlying unknown big other though we
are nonetheless in the fact that there
could be entity either
I'm with that but what was going to say
to you here was this is my just like
just like you know science bases itself
on objective knowledge yeah scientific
method doesn't doesn't do that because
the scientific method itself it gives
you it gives you certain knowledge that
you can rely on a certain time period
but then that can be falsified like oh
yeah yeah it's not certain truth but I
feel like you know in different
situations you've reason different
outcomes to the certain outcomes do you
want right like if you're under threat
you wouldn't behave in the same way as
if you are unfretted
I'm with you but what my point to you is
like have you guys read vja Nietzsche
what book have you guys with is the
difficult book to me that you agree yeah
it's like the gay science world of the
book with the gay science
all right Mitch are people like
Nietzsche people like Bertrand Russell
atheist people like Derrida Jackie sorry
you know these are these are post
modernist yeah so basically they they
they don't believe that objective
morality exists so if I said to you
objectively can you prove that
homosexuality is a sin you say no you
can't yeah you can't prove it
objectively see it from your perspective
but can you prove this it's a good thing
to do no and the same thing would I
believe I can prove he's a good thing to
do in the sense that I feel loved
I feel empowered I feel like it gives me
a sense of belonging and I think that
through expressing my homosexuality I've
been able to be a more authentic version
of myself with more Society so I think I
can prove in a sense the object you
don't think that because the morality
has a very certain philosophical
connotation I guess I guess the struggle
is I don't really believe in that many
things that are objective and no matter
what situation you're in it is objective
but at the same time I could give you
anecdotal and like just real life
experiences that have proven sin myself
and many others only subjective because
I don't believe in objective morality
and I don't believe there's a bright way
don't you that's wrong I'm not saying to
you that you're not entitled to that
okay okay I'm Jenny I'm not saying that
I'm just saying that so it's very
difficult for us here from a non
objective perspective to actually
condemn anything morally
so even if I said because you said that
it causes me love innocent act like I
feel you said my homosexuality makes me
feel XY I said yeah I'm saying to you
like Hitler might felt good when he was
sorry but like when he was doing what he
was doing
it doesn't it doesn't mean that because
of that feeling that that messes that
necessarily means that was doing is
moral good but at the same time killed
millions of people I feel good and like
I'm not stopping anyone else to come
back to the humphrey'd support yeah can
we prove that liberalism is true
you know liberalism the one that we
described by John Stuart Mill on Liberty
you know the book can we prove that that
idea that ideology is a true ideology
objectively discussion that you think
okay listen guys I want to see them
again so I say to you the following
thing yeah two points I made two now I
want to be I want to reiterate when it
comes to the issue of homosexuality I
said to them why'd you do you accept
that so long as you can do everyone so
long as about how many one else yeah I
mean it's hard to measure yeah yeah but
you said you accept that as a maximum to
measure how the ramifications of how you
behave affecting other people fight them
with you so you have to as an objective
Maxim what I'm saying to you right here
and right now is that first of all we're
not going to prove that
we'll come up with that and you know
that right we can't prove that it's an
objective Martin but even if we applied
that objective maximum yep we'll put it
into practical usage we've realized that
you'd have to allow incest to occur and
you said you don't like it for
naturalistic reasons but what I'm saying
to you is that those creationists who
make the same what is the difference
like why is it why is it for comparison
wicked incest is it's an act that
involves like very complicated dynamics
of mothers and children
I told you before that the word power
has philosophical conversations which
you have to unpack and people define it
differently so microphone call Robert
Dahl and you know ambiguity in the
sexual attraction there's a lot of
ambiguity in the way we relate to each
other like what can I tell you what I
think I think the reason why
homosexuality is accepted and
is not as accepted it's because in the
1960s and 70s you had a movement of
homosexuals that came out publicly
demanding rights and that was listening
to you by society and it became the
social norm had you had the same
movement for insert for people that
practice in says it's a high school
situations and debates we talk about
individual freedom we talk about person
that wants to be in an incestuous
relationship should have his individual
freedom as well yeah of course but okay
you can talk about sort of
universalizing okay there's a problem
because as I said like when you asked me
I said if they were 18 years
relationship I wouldn't say that was
it's very strange because I know but
they're not children anymore safe either
Woody Allen adopted a child she grew up
when she hey teen he started getting
with her and then he and I generally
don't think anything was wrong with her
okay no I know but I don't think the
relationship is a relationship of equal
power or a relationship I'm gonna stop
even my power because that's the only
thing you have to cut me down okay I
don't think the relationship there is
one that views there to be was liking
for people because my mother has taught
all their fathers taught the girls this
is how he should live your life but
equality is once again you can't prove
the objectively coming I can't prove
anything to you objectively because I
don't really believe in objective tracer
it's kind of like an on point
I can't oh okay right so do you see okay
what I'm saying Shu is the following now
that we have to be whatever paradigm we
want to work within we have to be
morally consistent yeah I'm so I'm a
Muslim the what I believe in is that
basically God yeah he had there were
prophets that came before time that God
revealed a message that he is singular
he's one etcetera except it's all his
prophets and that these prophets came
with two things they came with an
evidence base and they came with a
message the message is that the he was
one God is one etc and that you have to
obey God
that's the message in that message so we
are there's basically God's expectations
we have to be in that message I'm saying
to that we believe that homosexuality
the act of penetration sorry to be sure
girl by the question of why the answer
of it is a straightforward question the
paradigm is that God knows best yeah
yeah so the coast are we selling us is
wrong but you're saying the active gay
states is wrong because of the act of
penetration
why is it wrong the answer from our
paradigm is because God said so and God
is all-knowing and that's subject to
morali therefore everything that comes
with an objective moral perspective ISM
is what we follow but even if you wanted
to use your your own words against
because you didn't mention natural
naturalistic things there you said that
incest is unnatural yeah
well I think we agreed that pointed out
at some stage but we were we could use
that very same argument against against
homosexuals throughout the whole of time
so disorders murder moralistic decision
they make naturally sicknesses remember
maximum that they don't get charged for
that did you know that the penguin if he
decides to enjoy is another penguin male
1 I do as a penguin then he doesn't but
look I tell you what yeah I I really
respect what you guys are coming from
because I feel like you do you know like
I feel like you've understood my
argument so I feel like free discussion
and conversation the one that we've had
today is a vitally important thing that
we should do in your opinion can Muslims
and homosexuals live side-by-side indeed
oh yeah look I mean the thing is yeah
this is I think one of the biggest
misconceptions where people actually
feel because of the things that's
happened down there like written in that
we are out here to kill civilians or
something like oh that we are here to do
to her hostage it's not believe it so we
don't believe in the Quran it says in
chapter 2 verse 256 let across 15 cacti
Bay and a verse terminal high it says
that there's no compulsion in religion
that the truth is very manifestly clear
from the falsehood so with that I will
conclude but look I'll tell you to do
one thing as if you don't mind yeah and
I know
can you do me a favor when you go home
start with no fraud because if you do a
PPE if you don't BBE you will get you
guys gonna have you're gonna have a good
insight in the world because I've done a
very similar course in Judea on politics
on politics on a postcard you in in
history and then after that but the
point is there was lots of motors you
know what you need I think what will
make you know around the person it's not
only to have idea of political
philosophy of you also have an
understanding of at least toward me well
made your religions like well we coming
from I know that were you're coming from
so you should know where I'm coming from
I'm not saying that you look I'm not
gonna treat you in an in a bad way I
don't like people that don't eat pork I
don't like I saw it even poor care but
I'm not gonna go stand outside the test
scores yeah oh this guy's got a I'm
saying what you pull a big guy let's
let's rush him let's not practically and
reasonably that's how we interact is
rationalism we believe in our
intellectualizing it and speaking an 11
genuinely not sugarcoating it not gonna
lie to you but also I'm not going to
treat you with any disrespect cuz that's
not the way of the professor that's not
what not dead when he met the people he
said to the people you know basically
abandon this act of homosexuality
abandon it you'll feel that your life is
probably going to get better if it
doesn't I promise you it will do you
know what it's not all about how you
feel from it from her sexual perspective
cata like me is the whole human being I
feel like I'm a more authentic version
of myself if I'm honest about my own
section feed you know you got ask
yourself a question now always the
purpose of life because because if you
answer that question properly then you
can answer why what would be the most
authentic version of you do I mean
you are authentic when you're doing your
purpose there's a basic human function
we go ask yourself why is that basic you
function you see what I'm saying yeah
fantastic
I'm gonna run now because I've got a
pray and go to these guys thank you so
much yeah brilliant
fantastic thank you very much thicker
[Music]